call me testifying right now we view
remiss not to ask you about it tight
even back to your work on civil
libertarian stuff how does this scandal
his testimony affect the climate for
dealing with surveillance issues and
things like that from your I don't know
how much effects can have on other
things I think that right now the
distraction of all things Russia and all
things Trump Russia is distracting us
from everything right now and I think it
has been overplayed I mean sounds like
and you can just imagine this if you
watch the president he's sitting there
with Comey and he saying am i target and
he says no mr. president you're not a
target tell the public then why won't
you tell the [ __ ] you can see him
browbeating him and saying I want the
public to know because it's distracting
from my agenda and you do kind of wonder
if he really isn't a target why they
wouldn't say that publicly and you can
go into all the debate over whether or
not he was bringing undue pressure on
him but the bottom line is is as Comey
testified today
nobody told me never not to investigate
this stuff
you